first of all i want to start with
congrats on the season uh you guys
totally nailed it uh fans are going to
be super happy as well as super upset
it's so it's
you know it's one of those things but
before we get into it i think a lot of
fans actually you guys look very similar
so i just want to throw out there for
fans can you each say your name on
camera so people can actually know who's
talking with ease
that's right uh i'm ross and i'm matt
so i usually have longer hair
that's the easiest way to tell the
difference that's true
right i'm not trying to by the way like
i just mean like i think a lot of people
would be like wait what you know like
internally we are uh we are identical
twins so we take no offense if you
confuse us no people have been confusing
us ever my entire life jumping into
before we get to stranger things you
guys just released a master class
and i'm so curious
at any point were you like wait they're
they're asking us to do a master class
like we like you guys are super
successful but you've made one show
i mean you know no it's bizarre but i
was like i was like are you sure you're
calling the right people
um
you know no it was super flattering and
and then and then you know we just
thought well um
you know there were so many things
you know
where
we struggled for a really long time to
figure out how to write scripts i mean
initially we just want we're just
dreamed of being directors and it wasn't
until we were in college that we're like
okay nobody's gonna let us direct unless
we have a script and we say you can't
have it unless you direct that was like
the the only smart thing i idea i came
up with in college
and uh and and then it was then it just
took a long time for us to figure out
how to write and there were so many and
we're from north carolina we had no
hollywood connections out here
um i mean zero i mean we went to school
in orange county and it was even that
felt far away so
um we're like well i think there's a lot
of things i wish someone had told me um
as an outsider that and so i do not
consider myself a
master of anything but i do think man
i've learned a lot over the past like 15
years maybe it helps some
somebody who's who's trying who's trying
to do this and then it's also for anyone
who's interested in how stranger things
came to be i mean you don't have to want
to be a writer hopefully to find the
show or the class interesting you could
just like the show you guys are clearly
perfectionists did you end up spending
way more time on doing the master class
than you expected
oh yeah absolutely but it was you know
it was a fascinating process mostly you
know thank god for google docs because
you know go i went back into you know
our original outline and you know it
saves everything you know with uh with
time machines so it was actually
fascinating to go back and like what was
day one of brainstorming on stranger
things when we first came up with the
idea and so it was interesting to sort
of go back and see how it evolved and
try to communicate that to the audience
but i think
just the fact that we have every tiny
idea documented i think is interesting
so you know it's it was cool to you know
share right we don't use whiteboard so
we use we've always just used google
docs so everything you know you see in
real time actually we found the moment
we came up with with eleven and you know
we shared that and you know so it was
actually you know it was it was it was a
lot of fun
um
but yeah i was juggling doing that with
doing post on stranger things five was a
little slightly stressful
but i think it was a world thing i'm so
curious obviously you guys have such a
juggernaut with stranger things but i'm
sure your agents are also like can you
do something else while you're doing
stranger things or do they leave you
alone or they constantly sort of on you
i mean you know or especially once
season one broke you know you start you
know getting more
offers of other ip and things like that
and but i think
we discussed it and at a certain point
we went no we want to tell the story and
finish it we don't want to try to hand
it off we want to see this all the way
through so that was communicated pretty
early on and everyone everyone got on
board so really only now as we're seeing
that finish line
approach are we starting to discuss what
what that next next thing is yeah people
used to bring his stuff but they don't
really bring things like we said no
enough that they stopped
yeah i think i think my next question is
probably the most important i'm going to
ask you in this entire interview uh who
is better at the stranger things pinball
machine
oh well i have
that that is fortunately me
um i i'm not great at pinball but i'm
better at pinball
i'm not better at pinball than my
brother but i currently have the high
score but here's the the truly
embarrassing thing is i was like i have
the high score in my we both have a
machine at our house that was like in
the pinball contract i was like i gotta
get my own
pinball machine
and this whole thing came about because
david and dan from game of thrones had
that game of thrones pinball machine
and i was like super jealous of that i
said how did you make that happen and
they're like be sure to put in the
contract that you get your own machine
so anyway that's why we both have our
own machines
is because of game of thrones and dan
and david anyway i have the top scorer
at my house but then there were
renovations happening in my house it was
like a
i don't want to go into
what um
my house situation but then i was always
staying over my brothers for a week and
i took his top score
at his house which is just
brutal it's a mat it's a matter of time
before that that it's been about seems
to be clear like five months since it
happened
and i have a baby i have a baby like so
there's no
he's got no excuse all right well it's
coming that sports uh changing for
people that have not actually played the
stranger things pinball it's really good
and it's totally worth it's just you
know it's hard to find it's like a
limited edition you know what i mean
it's a great it they did a terrific job
with it um it's really great i think
there's like a pin what is it there's
like a there's a pinball version of imdb
and i think we're like it's called it's
pin side inside yeah and we're like
we're definitely at least in the top 30
or 25 or something it's a good machine
it's a great machine yeah they're
getting better they keep updating it's
like i didn't realize i'm learning so
much about pinball but they update it
they patch it sort of like you can patch
it sort of like you patch video games
right you i mean you know this but like
i didn't know that so it just keeps it
yeah it just keeps improving it's very
hard to get the ball in the mouth of the
demogorgon though
so i don't even try because you're going
down right in the middle of the lane and
i think it's just super dangerous so i
was like i just don't do it anymore and
i think that's the key to my success
i'll just stay clear of the demogorgon i
just let him roar at me and then go away